November 17th 1918 Germany had given up the week
before an armistice term is demanded the turning
over of the darkspawn fleet to the victorious
Allies within the week 20 miles of German warships
gave up here the youthful Prince of Wales of all
the USS New York watches as the terms of British
Admiral Sir David fede are carried out king
george v is present in the Firth of Forth as
Germany's beaten battle wagons bound to the pact
made between Admiral Beatty and its Rear Admiral
von Mira naval death of a defeated nation Admiral
Beatty Admiral rotman King George the Prince of
Wales and Admiral Sims included in Germany's
sea power to be interned and disarmed but the
terms of the armistice are six battle cruisers
ten battleships eight light cruisers including
two mine layers 50 destroyers and a scourge of
the underwater underworld the u-boats even as
these surface warships steam past Allied ships
even though Germany has officially given up the
kaisers Navy is not trusted and jacked ours on
British men of war are up there battle stations
waiting for the first indication of treachery
ready to blast the enemy ships to the bottom
fight these fears the surrender was made without
incident the greatest naval force ever to haul
down its flag was handed over without a shot
being fired only once was this battle force in
action may 31st 1916 saw the Battle of Jutland
a tremendous victory for the British Navy never
again during World War one was the German
fleet to venture from its harbour dreaded
u-boats which menaced a bar shipping all during
the war rise to the surface to join the parade
of defeat but this story is not over even though
the surrendered vessels will tarry by their own
crews to scapa flow off the Scottish coast for
in June 1919 the same German seamen who were
interned with their ships after the surrender
succeeded in scuttling many of them these scenes
you are watching are the epic climax of the
conflict that began with Germany's invasion
of Belgium and ended with the defeat of Germany a
downfall of the horns on on ruling family and the
passing of control to a friction flow political
party that formed the Hitler of World War two